what are the top 5 supports for Samira?
let's talk about it now.
I love to play Samira
so I can be the first one to tell you
she loves tanki,
peel and engage.
so if you're thinking of a tank,
and if you think that they have engaged,
and if you think that they have peel,
it's for Samira.
so coming in at number 5,
I'm putting recon on this list.
he can go in
and he can go out in a flash with that dash,
just like Samira.
well, Samira can't go out anymore, but
rip. but once he goes in, he can knock up,
he can charm them their sea seed forever.
samira gets that dash off
and she can also extend them in the air.
and while they're charmed,
Samira can just ulti
and there's nothing that they can do.
they just die.
so coming in at number 4 is
Galio, y'all.
I still don't know why to this day
Galio is just left on support.
he has shields,
he has knock ups,
he has taunts,
he has knock ups again.
it's like. but he's everything,
so Samira works wonderfully with him.
next up coming in at number 3.
this list would be incomplete without this man, Nautilus.
y'all know he's the CC king, so
I really don't.
I don't need to explain this one.
there's the hook,
there's the knock up from his ulti,
there's his root,
he's tanky, he's engaged,
he's got CC,
he can easily proc that passive for Samira
by getting the knock off off of his ulti.
but also she can get endless dash
is to these opponents through his root.
so it's really just after each auto
it's just dash, dash,
go in, go ham, go crazy,
go Samira, go Samira!
number 2. oh my gosh,
when I see this combo, it's over.
it's over for you hoes.
like, legitimately
next is Alistar. bro,
if an Alistar truly,
truly knows his combo,
you don't get to play the game.
and if that Alistar
sticks with Samira for the full duration of the game,
you don't get to play the game.
they are an uncertain,
unstoppable combo.
not only because Alice Star is like,
tanky for absolutely no reason.
I mean, he's a bull,
so I guess it makes sense,
but like, that's not really the.
that's not the point.
the point is
you can't kill that man.
so if you can't get through him,
how you gonna get to Samira?
and by the way,
you got knock up,
you got knocked back,
you got stunned,
you got rude, you.
where are you going?
because as long as Alice Star is nearby,
the answer is.
let me check my notes.
the answer is nowhere.
okay, enough chitchat.
let's get into number one.
number one, samira
support y'all. and like,
I feel bad because this champion is deceased currently,
but they worked so hard,
so well together on release, y'all.
samira and rell,
rell, honey, you are beautiful.
she's got the knock up,
she's got the stun,
she's got the.
I don't know what you call her ulti,
the gravitational pull.
she's got it and it works amazingly.
it's just Rell is.
I mean, who plays Rell?
if you a real main,
sound off in the comments.
I wanna see you represent.
I mean a lot of these champs in this list
are perfect for Samira.
that's why they're on the list.
and that's why I'm perfect,
cause I put the list together. like,
round of applause for me.
like yes, you're so smart anyways